foreign
of The Last Jedi between Prince William
and Prince Harry Stephanie you think he
was Harry Harry was you know Harry is
just more cash with me did everyone on
set know that it was them yeah they
walked on with with the costumes on
there's something about royalty it just
seeps right in the suit you know
and that royalty was on full display as
William and Kate took on their first
official engagement since the funeral
today the palace released this photo of
King Charles taken last week at
Buckingham there's a pic of his late
mother in the background with Prince
Philip
the crown which caused filming for the
funeral resume production yesterday in
Spain recreating Princess Diana scenes
with her sons and remember this scene
from Monday's Memorial that was such a
touching image of the
two cookies lined up watching the
passing of the the hearse only E.T is
with the men behind the Queen's beloved
animals horse trainer Monty Roberts and
Dr Roger mugford who oversaw and dared
to comment on her growing dog pack about
30 corgis over the years you've got 10
or 11 dogs in the room here and that's
probably six or seven dogs too many she
said rather abruptly to me look this is
what Philip's been saying all the time
if I thought you were going to tell me
I've got too many dogs I'm I would have
listened to Philip and saved your fee
she had always eight or ten of them and
she said no I'm not going to take on any
more because I don't want to leave any
behind
Monty hopes to carry out one of the
Queen's final wishes to go forth and do
herb
bidding
to take violence out of the training of
horses she was very careful to be as
fair with her horses as she could
possibly be it was wonderful
[Music]